SO YOU'VE JUST HEARD WHY OUR
NOMINEES FOR ANIMATED SHORTS
FELL IN LOVE WITH ANIMATION.
ME?
I FELL IN LOVE WITH ANIMATED MOVIES
WHEN MY MOTHER TOOK ME
TO A MOVIE THEATER FOR THE VERY
FIRST TIME TO SEE THE ANIMATED
MOVIE CALLED,
"THE SECRET OF NIMH."
I REMEMBER VIVIDLY THE
LEAD CHARACTER
WAS MRS. BRISBY
AND SHE WAS A FIERCE MOTHER
MOUSE DETERMINED TO PROTECT HER
CHILDREN FROM A DANGEROUS
FARMER'S PLOW.
IT WAS MY FIRST EXPERIENCE SEEING A
STRONG WOMAN AT THE CENTER OF A FILM.
AND THAT IS THE POWER OF REALLY
GREAT ANIMATION.
IT SHOWS YOU, AS A CHILD, THAT
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
THAT YOU CAN CHANGE THE WORLD,
EVEN IF YOU'RE AS SMALL AS A MOUSE.
TONIGHT, WE HAVE NOMINEES
HERE WITH US IN PERSON,
BUT WE WANT TO SAY A SPECIAL HELLO
TO THOSE JOINING US
FROM LONDON AND
KILKENNY, IRELAND.
[ APPLAUSE ]
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR BEST
ANIMATED FEATURE.
"ONWARD,"
DAN SCANLON AND KORI RAE
"OVER THE MOON," GLEN KEANE,
GENNIE RIM AND PEILIN CHOU
"A SHAUN THE SHEEP MOVIE:
FARMAGEDDON"
RICHARD PHELAN, WILL BECHER
AND PAUL KEWLEY
"SOUL," PETE DOCTER
AND DANA MURRAY
"WOLFWALKERS"
TOMM MOORE, ROSS STEWART,
PAUL YOUNG AND
STEPHAN ROELANTS.
AND THE OSCAR FOR BEST
ANIMATED FEATURE GOES TO --
"SOUL."
PETE DOCTER AND
DANA MURRAY
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WOW. OKAY
I'VE BEEN NOMINATED
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF DANA AND KEMP POWERS,
OUR CO-DIRECTOR.
THIS FILM STARTED AS A LOVE
LETTER TO JAZZ,
BUT WE HAD NO IDEA HOW MUCH
JAZZ WOULD TEACH US ABOUT LIFE.
LIKE WE DON'T GET TO CONTROL
WHAT HAPPENS, BUT WE CAN,
LIKE A JAZZ MUSICIAN,
TURN WHATEVER HAPPENS INTO
SOMETHING OF VALUE AND
SOMETHING OF BEAUTY.
AND THAT WAS CERTAINLY TRUE
OF OUR AMAZING CAST:
JAMIE FOXX, TINA FEY, YOU GUYS ARE AMAZING.
OUR BRILLIANT COLLABORATORS
TRENT REZNOR AND ATTICUS ROSS,
JON BATISTE, THIS GUY OVER THERE.
IT WAS JUST FANTASTIC, WORKING
WITH ALL YOU GUYS.
OUR CULTURAL CONSULTANTS
DR. JOHNNETTA COLE.
PEOPLE WHO KEPT US HONEST
AND KEEP THOSE CHARACTERS TRUTHFUL.
WE'RE REALLY THANKFUL TO OUR
PARTNERS AT DISNEY WHO,
WHEN WE SAID, “HEY, WE WANT TO
DO A FILM THAT EXPLORES
THE PURPOSE OF LIFE,” THEY'RE LIKE,
“OKAY, GO AHEAD.”
THAT'S NOT YOUR USUAL
CARTOON FARE.
AND OF COURSE, TO OUR FAMILY.
DANA WANTS TO THANK…
>> MY AMAZING HUSBAND, MY PARENTS.
I'M HERE BECAUSE OF YOU.
I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
HAZEL AND MURRAY, MY BABIES AT HOME.
YOU'RE EVERYTHING TO ME.
WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO THANK
THE CREW WHO MADE THIS FILM
AND EVEN FINISHED IT FROM HOME
WITH SEVEN WEEKS OF PRODUCTION LEFT.
YOU ARE, YOU SHOULD BE UP
HERE WITH US,
AND WE ARE JUST THE
LUCKY SPEAKERS.
I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
SPEAKING ACTUALLY.
>> SO OUR MAIN CHARACTER, JOE,
IS A MUSIC TEACHER.
WE WANT TO THANK MUSIC TEACHERS
AND ART TEACHERS EVERYWHERE.
YOU, INCLUDING MY PARENTS,
DAVE AND RITA, AND DANA'S PARENTS,
PAM AND TOM, YOU MAKE THE
WORLD A BETTER PLACE.
AND MY WISH FOR ALL OF US TONIGHT
IS THAT WE COULD FOLLOW
THE EXAMPLE OF JAZZ MUSICIANS
THAT WHEREVER WE ARE,
WHATEVER WE HAVE,
WE TURN IT INTO SOMETHING BEAUTIFUL.
THANK YOU.